Transcriber:
Let's talk about regret.
It is, to my mind,
our most misunderstood emotion,
and so I decided to spend
a couple of years studying it.
And one of the things
that I did is I went back
and I looked at about 50 years
of social science on regret.
And here's what it tells you.
I'll save you the trouble of reading
a half century of social science.
The research tells us
that everybody has regrets,
regrets make us human.
Truly, the only people
without regrets are five-year-olds,
people with brain damage and sociopaths.
The rest of us, we have regrets,
and if we treat our regrets right,
and that's a big if,
but there are ways to do it,
regrets can actually make us better.
They can improve
our decision-making skills,
improve our negotiation skills,
make us better strategists,
make us better problem solvers,
enhance our sense of meaning
if we treat them right.
And the good news is that there's
a systematic way to do that.
But I want to take just a few minutes
to tell you about another aspect of regret
that I think is really, really
just super interesting.
As part of the research here,
I decided to ask people for their regrets,
and to my surprise,
I ended up collecting about 16,000 regrets
from people in 105 countries.
It’s an extraordinary trove.
And what I realized when I went through
this incredible database
of human longing and aspiration
is that around the world,
and there's very little
national difference here,
people kept expressing
the same four regrets.
Around the world,
there are the same four regrets
that keep coming up
over and over and over again.
So what I want to do is just
quickly tell you
about these four core regrets,
because I think they reveal something
incredibly important and interesting.
So the four core regrets
that I'm going to cover.
Number one, what I call
foundation regrets.
Foundation regrets.
These are people
who regret things like this:
not saving enough money,
which would be like, you know,
financial regret,
not taking care of their health
and not eating right, health regret.
But they're the same.
Those kinds of regrets
are about making choices
that didn't allow you
to have some stability,
a stable platform for their life.
I have a lot of people who regret
not working hard enough in school.
A lot of people who regret --
I got a lot of regrets
about not saving money.
And it reminds me a little bit
of Aesop’s fable
of the ant and the grasshopper,
where earlier in their life they acted
like a grasshopper instead of the ant,
and now it's catching up with them.
So foundation regrets sound like this:
"If only" --
And that's the catch phrase
of regret, "if only" --
"If only I'd done the work."
Second category.
I love this category, it's fascinating.
Boldness regrets.
I have hundreds of regrets
around the world that go like this:
“X years ago, there was a man/woman
whom I really liked.
I wanted to ask him/her out on a date,
but I was too scared to do it
and I've regretted it ever since."
I also have hundreds of regrets
by people who said:
"Oh, I always wanted to start a business,
but I never had the guts to do that."
People who said: “Oh, I wish
I’d spoken up more.
I wish I'd said something
and asserted myself."
These are, as I said before,
what I call boldness regrets.
And we get to a juncture in our life
and we have a choice.
We can play it safe
or we can take the chance.
And what I found is overwhelmingly
people regret not taking the chance.
Even people who took the chance
and it didn't work out
don't really have many regrets about that.
It's the people
who didn't take the chance.
So this is boldness regrets.
Boldness regrets sound like this:
"If only I'd taken the chance."
Third category.
Moral regrets.
Very interesting,
very interesting category.
These are people who, again,
a lot of these regrets
begin at a juncture.
You're at a juncture,
you can do the right thing
or you can do the wrong thing.
People do the wrong thing,
and they regret it.
I mean, one of the ones
that really stuck with me,
I'm going to try to pull it up here,
is this one here, this woman.
She's a 71-year-old woman in New Jersey.
"When I was a kid,
my mother would send me
to a small local store for a few items.
I frequently would steal a candy bar
when the grocer wasn't looking.
That's bothered me for about 60 years."
So 71-year-old woman in New Jersey,
for 60 years, she's been bugged
by this moral breach.
So moral regrets.
We have people regretting bullying,
we have people regretting
marital infidelity.
All kinds of things.
Moral regrets sound like this,
“If only I’d done the right thing.”
And finally, our fourth category,
or what I call connection regrets.
Connection regrets are like this:
You have a relationship
or ought to have a relationship.
And it doesn't matter
what the relationship is.
Kids, parents, siblings,
cousins, friends, colleagues,
but you have a relationship
or ought to have had a relationship,
and the relationship comes apart.
And what's interesting is that what these
16,000 people were telling me
is that the way
these relationships come apart
is often not very dramatic,
not very dramatic at all.
They often come apart by drifting apart
rather than through
some kind of explosive rift.
And what happens is that people
don't want to reach out
because they say it’s going to be
awkward to reach out,
and the other side is not going to care.
One of the lessons that I learned
from this book for myself
is always reach out.
So that's what connection regrets are.
"If only I'd reached out."
And so over and over and over again,
we see these same regrets:
Foundation regrets:
“If only I’d done the work.”
Boldness regrets:
“If only I’d taken the chance.”
Moral regrets: “If only
I’d done the right thing.”
And connection regrets:
“If only I’d reached out.”
And when we look at these regrets,
so that's interesting in itself,
but what I realized is that these
four core regrets
operate as a kind of
photographic negative of the good life.
Because if we understand
what people regret the most,
we actually can understand
what they value the most.
And each of these regrets, to my mind,
reveals something fundamental
about humanity and about what we need.
We need stability.
Nobody wants to have an unstable life.
We want a chance to learn
and grow and do something.
We recognize that we are not here forever,
and we want to do something
and try something.
And at least feel
the exhilaration of being bold.
Moral regrets, I think most of us,
almost all of us
want to do the right thing.
At some level, these moral regrets
are very heartening.
The idea that people are bugged
for years, decades,
by these moral breaches
earlier in their life.
I think most of us
want to do the right thing.
And then connection regrets.
We want love, not love only
in the romantic sense,
but love in the broader sense
of connection and relationship
and affinity with other people.
And so in a weird way,
this negative emotion of regret
points the way to a good life.
By studying regret, we know
what constitutes a good life,
a life of stability,
a life where you have a chance
to take a few risks,
a life where you’re doing the right thing
and a life where you have people
who love you and whom you love.
And so to me, I started out saying,
“Oh, boy, is this book
going to be a downer, studying regret?”
And it ended up being very uplifting.
And so, those are the four core regrets.
Regret points us to the good life.
And so I hope that you'll begin
to reckon with your own regrets
because I think they're going to give you
direction to a life well lived.
Whitney Pennigton Rogers:
Well, thank you for that, Dan
I was clapping behind the scenes
when you couldn't actually see me,
for everyone who I know also really
appreciated what you shared there.
First, Dan, you mentioned,
you know, this big takeaway
about how thinking about regret
can help us figure out
what is the recipe for the good life.
I guess what has been your biggest
takeaway from doing this work beyond that?
DHP: I found it really interesting
how much people want to talk about this,
and that's what got me on it
in the first place.
That is, I had an experience in my life
where one of my kids
graduated from college,
and that sort of marker in my life
made me start thinking
about what regrets that I had.
And I just mentioned it to a few people,
and I found them, like,
leaning in to the conversation.
So I was amazed at how much
people want to talk about this
and how much this taboo of like,
“Oh, I don’t have any regrets,”
is so ridiculous.
I mean, it's absurd.
And that if we actually
start talking about it,
we're going to be better off.
For me personally, I think
that the biggest takeaway was the ...
Was the connection regrets.
Because I had so many people
who had the same story
where they had a friendship,
some kind of relationship,
and it comes apart,
and they want to reach out and they say,
"Oh no, it's going to be really awkward.
And the other side's not going to care."
And we're so wrong about that.
It's not awkward, and the other side
almost always appreciates it.
And so for me,
I guess the takeaway is
if I'm at a juncture in my life
where I'm thinking,
“Should I reach out
or should I not reach out?”
I've answered the question.
That the answer to that question
at that juncture,
if you reach that juncture,
the answer is, always reach out.
You know, especially coming out
a time like this, Whitney,
we need that sense of of connection.
And so the ethic of always reaching out,
to me, is one of the best life lessons
that I've learned.
WPR: Well, we're going to do something
a little interesting next, Dan,
which is have some Members
share their own regrets.
And so I want to, I guess,
hand things over to you right now
so that you can bring in our first Member
and we can explore more
what this process of thinking
about making our regrets
help us live the good life
actually looks like.
DHP: Sure, sure.
And so let's bring on Lily.
I don't want it to sound like a magic act,
but Lily and I don't know each other.
We haven't gone through this before,
but what I want to try to do is actually,
the hearing of the stories
of people's regrets
I think is super
interesting and revealing.
We’re going to hear Lily’s regret,
and we're going to talk through
what science says
might be some appropriate
responses to that.
So, Lily, welcome.
Lily: Thank you, hi everyone.
DHP: And tell us where you are.
L: I'm currently in Brooklyn, New York.
DHP: Brooklyn is in the house
here at TED Membership.
So Lily, tell us you regret.
L: Yeah. So my regret that I want to share
is that for most of my young adult life
from kindergarten, really,
straight through high school
is that I was painfully, painfully shy
with really low self-confidence.
As I was thinking about this,
I was remembering,
and there were times where I just
wanted to close my eyes
and be invisible.
And I think that, you know, my ...
Like, I didn't really come into my own
until I got to college,
where I found a really great
group of friends,
really, like, I was confident
in expressing myself
and, you know, just being myself.
And I think that, you know,
my regret is that I just really wish
I had taken a little bit more effort
to build my confidence
to fight this a little bit more,
because I worry about what opportunities
I might have missed.
So ever since then, I feel like
I try to counteract it now.
And if ever I meet someone
who might be going through,
especially if they're younger, like going
through the same thing I did,
I try to make them feel seen
and try to empathize
with how they're feeling.
So that's kind of a takeaway,
I guess, from that regret.
DHP: But I mean, it sounds like ...
So is this a regret that's still with you?
L: I think ...
DHP: It sounds to me like you might have
sort of begun the process
of resolving it a little bit.
L: Absolutely.
But I think that, you know,
even just, you know, prepping for this,
I start to think about like, you know,
there could have been more things
that I could have done
if I had just put myself
a little bit out there,
if I didn't, just try to hide so much.
DHP: OK, alright.
This is fascinating, Lily,
and I have to say,
I have this database of regrets.
And you can search the database.
And if I were to search the database
for the phrase "speak up,"
"spoke up," "spoken up,"
I would get huge,
huge numbers of of people.
It is one of the most common regrets,
is that people regret not speaking up.
The important thing about our regrets
that comes from the science is this:
it's how we deal with them.
So we can take that regret and say,
"You know what?
It doesn’t matter that I feel terrible
and I have this regret,
because I'm just
going to ignore it," right?
That's like the blithe
"no regrets" philosophy.
That's a bad idea, alright?
The other way at it is to say,
"Oh my God, I have all these regrets,
it's so terrible,
I'm going to wallow in them."
That's a bad idea too.
What we want to do,
and I think that you've already done
a really brilliant job of it
is use these regrets as signals.
Signals for our thinking;
what is it teaching me?
And so there are a few things
in the research
that give us some clues about what to do.
So one of them is this.
So we start with sort of,
reframing the regret
and how we think about it in ourselves.
So do you think that you are the only
person with this kind of regret?
L: I don't know.
DHP: Not at all.
I’m watching the chat, man.
Somebody said, “Lily,
you’re telling my story.”
So one of the things
that we can do with our regret
is treat ourselves
with self-compassion, alright?
Not boost our self-esteem,
that's sometimes dangerous.
Not rip ourselves down
with self-criticism,
but actually say,
treat ourselves with kindness
rather than contempt
and recognize that what
we're going through
is part of the shared human experience.
That's one thing.
The second thing that we can do
is we can disclose our regret.
And there are few things
that are interesting about disclosure.
There's something amazing
why 16,000 people
were willing to share
their regrets with me.
I mean, like, what's
going on there, right?
And the reason is that when
we disclose our regrets,
we relieve some of the burden.
That's one thing.
The second thing that we do
is that when we actually talk
about our regrets,
converting these kind of blobby mental
abstractions into concrete words,
whether it's spoken or writing,
defangs them.
It begins the sense-making process.
And the other thing about disclosure,
which is a dirty little secret
that I'll reveal to all of you
that comes out
in the research very clearly,
is that when we disclose
our vulnerabilities and our weaknesses,
people don't like us less,
they actually like us more.
Because they empathize with us.
They respect our courage.
And the final thing is to actually
try to extract a lesson from it,
to use this regret.
So what would you say, Lily,
is the lesson that you've learned
from this regret?
L: I think that ...
What would have gone wrong if I ...
DHP: That's interesting.
L: If I were more open
about expressing myself,
like, people might discover
I'm a little weird,
or they might think that maybe I'm nice
and hopefully maybe a little funny.
So I think, like, maybe
that's one thing that jumps to mind.
Like, what could have gone wrong?
You know.
DHP: So what's the lesson
that you have applied going forward?
Taking this regret, OK,
so you've sort of treated yourself
with kindness rather than contempt.
You've disclosed it
to all these people here.
You've begun the sense-making process
by talking about it and writing about it.
What's a lesson that you can
extract from this?
L: I think that ...
I'm not sure.
DHP: Well, then let me tell you.
(Laughs)
I think that the lesson is to ...
Next time, speak up.
Next time when you are at a juncture,
"Should I speak up or not,"
think about this.
Think about this and speak up.
Do you have any kind of work meetings
or anything coming on
where you're going to be
confronted with this?
L: Yeah, and I think
that happens all the time.
Like, you know, I have an idea.
Oh, but someone starts talking,
and then like, you just sort of
fade back into the background,
and that’s something
I want to counteract more often.
Because, more often than not,
you know that idea is a contribution,
and why am I hesitating so much?
DHP: Yeah.
So you have a lesson.
The lesson is, speak up.
So why don't you --
So how about the next meeting you're in,
when you have something to say,
don't hesitate and speak up.
L: Done, I'll do it.
DHP: OK, but here's the thing,
what I like about this is you've just
made a promise to 300 people.
So you're on the hook.
L: I'm on the hook.
DHP: So this is it.
So, Lily has this regret.
She's looking backwards, saying,
"Oh, if only I'd spoken up,"
and instead of beating herself up,
she is divulging it,
she's extracting a lesson from it,
and she's taking that and applying
it to some next interaction.
So this is what we do.
This is how, again, looking backward
can move you forward.
Lily, that's such a fantastic --
People in the chat are saying,
"We will hold Lily accountable,"
which I love.
So Lily, thanks for that.
We're going to bring --
I really, really appreciate
your sharing that with us,
and I want you to report back
that you did speak up.
L: I will, thank you.
DHP: Thanks, Lily.
WPR: Well, we have a question here
from Claudia, who asks,
"Can you speak to the issue
of painful life regrets?
Major opportunities lost?
Do you have some advice
on how to avoid being paralyzed
by fear or further regret?"
DHP: Yeah.
It’s interesting that Claudia
said “opportunities lost,”
and let me pick up
on that phrase right here.
Because one of the things
I saw in my own research,
because I also did a huge survey
of the American population
where we surveyed
a representative sample of 4,489 Americans
about regret and how it worked.
But one of the things you see widespread
is that there are,
in the architecture of regret,
there are often two kinds of regrets.
One are regrets of action
and one are regrets of inaction.
Regrets about what we did.
Regrets about what we didn't do.
And overwhelmingly,
inaction regrets predominate.
And that's what an opportunity lost is.
With action regrets,
we can try to undo them.
We can make amends.
We can look for the silver lining,
and we can reduce the sting.
For inaction regrets, it is harder.
And so the key here
on the opportunities lost
is to think about,
you know, really like,
what are you going to do?
You sort of reduce
the level of abstraction and say,
"What are you going to do next time?"
Not an abstraction of like,
"Oh, I'm going to be more bold."
It's like, what are you
going to do next time?
This is what we were talking
about with Lily.
What are you going to do next time?
All regrets begin at the juncture.
You can go this way
or you can go that way.
And so for Claudia, I would say,
the next time you're at this juncture,
take the opportunity, play it safe.
Stop,
think about your regret,
and make the decision there.
Or another thing that you could do.
I'll give you another, sort of,
decision-making heuristic.
Two of them, in fact.
When you're at that juncture,
Claudia, next time,
go forward five years.
This is called self-distancing.
Be Claudia five years from now,
look back on Claudia today.
What decision do you want?
What decision does Claudia of 2027
want Claudia of 2022 to make?
It's very clear.
Or the best decision-making
heuristic there is:
You're at a juncture, what would you tell
your best friend to do?
When you ask people that
when they're trying to make a decision,
say, “What would you tell
your best friend to do?”
Everybody always knows.
So, I think that's it.
Remember, the main thing, though,
is don't let it bog you down.
Use it as a tool for thinking --
not as a tool for wallowing,
not as a tool for ignoring --
but as a tool for thinking.
WPR: A question from Kim, she's asking --
She says you're talking as if any
bad decision or mistake is also a regret,
and I'm not sure
that that's always the case.
Can you share your definition of regret?
Especially after doing this project.
What is your definition?
DHP: There's a difference between
a regret and a mistake, alright?
So you can make a mistake
and not regret it
because you say, you immediately
learn something from it
or it was a worthy mistake.
A regret is something where
you look backward at something
that where you had control,
where you had some agency ...
Where you had some agency,
you did something that, well,
you did something wrong,
and it sticks with you.
It doesn't go away.
And it sticks with you
for a very long time.
So there's a big difference,
for instance, between ...
I can make a mistake
and actually not regret it
because it's not significant enough
to me to linger, right?
So that's the difference
between a regret and a mistake.
It's basically the duration,
essentially, the half-life
of the negative emotion.
There's a huge difference
between regret and disappointment.
Huge difference between regret
and disappointment.
Because with disappointment,
you don't have any kind of control.
The great example of that
is from Janet Landman,
a former professor at the University
of Michigan who, to me, is like,
she tells the story of like, OK,
so a kid loses her third tooth.
A seven-year-old loses her third tooth.
She loses her tooth, she goes to sleep,
before she goes to sleep,
she puts the tooth under the pillow.
When she wakes up,
the tooth is still there.
The kid is disappointed,
but the parents regret not leaving that --
So you have to have some agency
and it has to have a ...
It has to have enough significance
that it stays with you.
And once again, going back
to these four core regrets,
it ends up being the same kinds of ...
it ends up being the same kinds of things.
If you said, "Oh, I shouldn't
have bought that kind of car,"
it might sting for a little bit,
but the half-life is very, very short.
But other kinds of things
stick with us and stick with us,
and those are the things
often of significance.
WPR: Thank you so much, Dan,
for chatting with us,
and I love ending there,
"If not now when?"
And we'll see you soon.
Thank you, Dan.
DHP: Thanks a lot, what a pleasure.
[Get access to thought-provoking events
you won't want to miss.]
[Become a TED Member
at ted.com/membership]